O ne o
[Müzik]
bu matematikte güzel 32 doğru yani bu
kadar gelişirse onlar daha geçeceğim
izler şimdi ben bu yapalım diye yaşamak
için gelmedim aslında hep çok
sevmişimdir ama
bizim evimizde Hayat dediğimiz
buharlandı bir geldi tanrısız olan
uzaklaşamaz
getirisi olan Bütün kararlar seçimler
yaşanmışlıklar sizin hayatınızı çekildi
mi
[Müzik]
ne olmuş Allah sonsuz ihtimalle son ses
alıcılarla örülmüş yaratılmış gelince
farklı varsa muzu
Yarın ejderha seçeceğiz yolu acele
yürürken çarptığımız diye bağırıyor
internette karşımıza çıkan Break yaka
bulacağız düşünmeden başvurduğumuz bir
okul izlediğiniz bir filmi okuduğumuz
bir kitap Bunların hepsi bambaşka
gelişmeler yaratma ve sizi Şu an
olduğumuzdan daha farklı bir insana
dönüştüğünü potansiyelimiz var
Eğer böyleyse hayatınızı ne kadar bizim
elimizde sayılı günler kala söyle
bağımızda kesişme lerimizi ne kadar
özverili
Evet şimdi
Görüşürüz saatlerce anlatabilirim desem
yüzünden daha fazla izinden
bahsedebilirim Belki de tanrı anlatırdım
nasıl her şeyin büyük bir güç tarafından
belirlenmiş bir nedene bağlı olduğunu ya
da hepimizin bu evrende biraz olduğunu
ve önceden yazılmış bir yazdığımız
olduğunu söyleyebilirim bu İstanbul
varlık yoktur programın tamamını
başından saldım Böylece evrenin bir
insanın sırrını yalnız 10 dakikada bir
konuşma söylememiş olurdu ama bu
bahsettiğim hiçbiri benim
yaşanmışlıkları benim gerçeklerin değil
Ben her zaman seni Şimdi aramızda Kendi
gelişmelerin çeyreğinde görmediğini
düşünen bir çok insan olabilir ki Haksız
da sayılmaz Belki ben bundan yanına
sonra şunu anlatmak üzere olduğum bu
hayatımı değiştiren kesişmeleri olanı
anlatmaya değer değil göreceğim ama
hayat ne kadar yaşadıysanız onları
vardır Şu kısacık Hayatında ilk kez
şişman altınları var
düşünün devlet okulundan mezun olmak
üzere bir ilkokul öğrencisi her okulun
bursluluk sınavına giren bir kız Emine
bazılarınız için çok sağlıklı profili
belki kendiniz Belki kendi çocuklarınız
da bu konuda olmuştur Bu ve kesişme
yaratan şey teyzemin duygusu görerek
anneme yansıdı tekrarlarsanız
girdiğimizde Türk Eğitim Derneği tam
eğitim bursluluk sınavı
İyi o zaman öğretmen farkında olmadan
geldiğini biliyorum bu sınava Hatta
moralim bozuk diye üzgün çıkmıştım
hiç unutmuyorum haftalar sonra başka bir
dershane sınavına gitmeye hazırlanırken
geldi telefon bana taneden sınav
istemediğimi sordum yazın son geçmişti
mülakatın vardı ya sanırım bugün annemde
bende güzel bir şey olacağını hissettik
Çünkü ben o kadar sana Sana gitmedim
mülakatı da geçtim kaçacağım gerekiyor
Okuldayım Okulu geziyoruz bakıyorum
kuaför salonu spor salonu her müzik eski
Onun için farklı bir sınıf dersleri için
dersi değiştiriyoruz benim
düşünebildiğim tek şey ben bu okulda
kaybolmadan nasıl olan faslını
geçireceğim
çok
Sonraları ise bir şekilde aradı ilgili
kaybolmadım iki günde değişti üçüncü gün
ortasındayım yemekhanede ilk
tanıştığımız birkaç arkadaşla oturuyoruz
işte nerden geldiğimizi konuşuyoruz
sonuçta da iki vuruyorsun Ben kilo hızla
geldim buraya Ben herkes için hemen
yardıma bahsediyor kimse onu da yaşıyor
şimdi daha İzmir'e yeni taşınmış ben de
karşı tarafa geldiğimi söyledim Hiç
yolundan arkadaşım vardı Acaba
Karşıyaka'da Kırtasiye var mı
tabii genci daha normal yeni taşınmış
ver ben orada sanki bu bir eksik gitmiş
gibi Karşıyaka'da Tabii ki Kırtasiye
olduğunu daha başka bir şey olduğunu
anlatmaya çalışıyorum orada
Ama şu an keşke o zamanki hali ne gidip
diyebilsem ki
bu
hissedeceksin sadece bekle ya Ben şu
anda Bursa'da öğrenci olduğunu gururla
söyleyebilirim 6 yıldır Okulu'nun
öğretmenlerinin arkadaşlarından ek
attıysa bana sınav salonunda geçeceğim
mülakatları harcadığım günler olmuştur
Bu kesişen olmuştu
her
tarafını kendisini görmek
seçimi bu kesişimi beni göndermişsin
şahit olmak kadar güzel dahi insanın
hiçbir şey yok hayatta bazı anlar bazı
seçimler vardır kendiniz
etrafınızdakilere karşınızdaki
bakarsınız bir düşünürsünüz ki işte bu
Bu benim hayatını tamamen değiştirecek
bu Türkiye pişirebilirsiniz Allahsız var
Olsun Tuğba abla açıktır bir Tam da bu
yüzden yapması lazım seçimler var bu
anlarda adımlarını daha yavaş atar daha
fazla düşürürsünüz bir şey yapmadan önce
şişeleri ise önceden kestirilemez
bu sıradan biri olan birisi olarak
adlandırılır un adlandırdığımız şeyler
size sonraki gelişebilir alır en büyük
en İzbe şişelerde kullanılmasında
burnunuzun duymadığı ellerin
tesadüflerden oynuyor başka ihtimaller
bambaşka Hayatlar sizin sonsuza kadar
fark eder işte Az önce bahsettiğim bu
tür geçiş
Sen benim karşıma çıkıp da dikkat et çok
önemli için yapmak üzeresin demişti
da alıyoruz Şimdi de yavrum buna benzer
bu kadar fazla hikaye var ki Doğru da
çalışmaların ki olmayan insanlar
yazılmıştır mı Onlar şu anda bu sahnede
Duran kişi şekillendirdi şimdi zaman
açıdan bir başvuru tarihi çok daha
severek yer aldığı program Lara
konferanslara etkinliklere götürdüm
Eğer
bu hareketlere gitme zıttı olarak vermek
üzere olduğu kararı seçmek üzere
olduğumu ağırlığı üzerinde hissettiğini
günler ve geceler oldu
demek istediğim isterse sandıklar ister
Bizler tarafından bir yapılmış olsun bir
kesi şeylerin izleri vardı
bu
insanlardan biri yumurta çoğu zaman
kendimi diğer insanları eleştirdiğin
daha soracağım
var ama bunu da benim bile edemeyeceği
tek bir şey varsa oluşudur Buket şeyler
her zaman başarı yapılmış olan
çok
kolay değil de benim için müziğinin Şu
an benimle bir şeyler için
yok ama başarısızlık herkesin
gelişmelerden çatlatma
insanları Türki bir kere benim
başarısızlığa buluşuruz Biliyorum şu an
kadar olmayınca bir şey hikayesi
Dinlediğiniz ama bugün hem Benim
konuşmamdan hemen önceki konuşmalarla
gördüğünüz ki Aslında bu başarıların
Ardında en az bir o kadar başarısızlık
ki bundan doğan bir şeyler yapacağız
doğada hiçbir şey kendi Karşılığı
olmadan bağlamaz başarılı olmasaydı Ya
biz bugün burada şeyden bahsedilmez
bu yanlışlar hatalar olmasaydı doğru TV
kavramları olmaz
ya o yüzden başarısızlığın doğru
olduğunu takip
Çünkü nasıl Ankara'dan bir şişeyle
konuşamıyorsa bir yemiyorsa siz de beni
başladığımız Her işte alanda başarılı
olamaz ama ben öncelikle oturmaya sonra
emeklemeye ve en sonunda ayağa kalkmayı
mahkumdur Hatta bundan sonra bile olunca
kez düşer girmeden önce Allahsız sesler
çıkarmanın heceleri öğrenmeniz ve ondan
kez denemeden sonra bile aslında kaç
tane anlamlı kelime oluşturur
ne
olacak bir şey almadan önce deneme
yanılmaya çabalamaya öğrenmek nedir
bu olarak hata yapmanı kötü beraber
çalışıyoruz olduğuna dair bir aldığımız
var ama hataların etrafında oluşturduğu
bu tablolarda başarısızlığı tahmin
dediğimiz olduğunu biz inandığım Bu
zihniyetten kurtulmamız gerekiyor
o Çünkü
başarısızlığa aslında
en temel yapı taşlarından
ve bu neler Pardon farkederseniz o kadar
fazla sıkılır o kadar fazla bir şey
demez
Bu gelişme lerimizden Korkma Çünkü
seçimler
bu
yaratılmış olsa da sizin elinizdedir
Ya aslında tüm anlattıklarıma rağmen bal
gelişmelerin oldu bundan başarı
başarısızlık hata doğrayalım şimdi
kavramlarla anlatabilecek yetişkinler
değillerdi
bundan bilmeyen sanata edebiyata Aşık
değildim Hayatımda en çok da son
yıllarda onlarca yüzlerce kitap oldu
Başka çağlarda başka dünyalarda bambaşka
insanlar olduğunu bir sürü hayatta şey
bilimin ve sanatın evliliğinde kayboldu
Hatta çoğu zaman kendi ve sorunlarını
üzülürdüm hali yok ya da Tek bildiğim
gördüğüm öğrendiğim her şeyin heyecanı
yaşadım öpücük sonsuzluk ları meydana
getirdiğim kişiler benim aklımı
duygularını düşüncelerini sırası olduğum
kişi şekil verdim bugün daha sonra
hayatımda yüzlerce binlerce kesişime
olacaklar ki başarısız olduğunu kadar
başarılı dolar
en yeni yerlere kitaplarını hallerini
bunlara bakmış belki sizde olan bir
kesimden sonra bir daha olmaz keseceğim
kesici kağıt üzerinde yaşam bize
tasarruflar getirecek bizi şeyler
yapacağız seçerseniz üçgeni kalkmayı
hata yapmayı Ağlamayı bilmeyen mutlu
olmayacağız olmayacağız Buket'i şeyler
ne kadar zor olursa olsun başkası
bilmediğimiz alabileceğinizi kendi
seçimlerini yapabileceğiz Çünkü kişi
şeyler bize yaşamıyoruz ve yaşamayı
öğrenmek kendimiz olmayabilir hepinize
teşekkür et